muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos
este vídeo este vídeo es una
actualización de uno que subimos hace
varios años y que tuvimos que eliminar
por problemas técnicos así que hemos
revisado el guión hemos actualizado los
datos y ahora os lo volvemos a presentar
porque países bajos es la mayor potencia
agrícola del mundo pues ahora mismo os
lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
buscarlo en google cuál es la mayor
potencia agrícola de europa muchos
pensaréis en españa' en italia o tal vez
en francia a fin de cuentas son países
con buen clima con miles de hectáreas de
tierra cultivable pero sin embargo
ninguno de estos países le llega a la
suela del zapato a países bajos también
conocido como holanda
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea holanda es
el mayor exportador de alimentos del
mundo sólo superado por eeuu qué decís
que no estáis sorprendidos pues pensadlo
bien hablamos de un país tan pequeño que
incluso tuvieron que construir diques
para ganarle terreno al mar de hecho es
uno de los países con más densidad de
población del mundo es decir que apenas
hay terreno disponible para cultivar
[Música]
a esto hay que sumarle que son uno de
los países más ricos y más modernos del
planeta el primer mercado de valores que
se creó en la historia fue la bolsa de
ámsterdam y seguro que todos conocéis
empresas holandesas como las el philips
o el banco ing normalmente cuando un
país tiene muchas empresas de industria
o servicios la agricultura pasa a un
segundo plano y os preguntaréis por qué
pues imaginad que tenemos un terreno por
ejemplo en españa' un terreno que mide
una hectárea si lo dedicamos a plantar
patatas podemos ganar entre unos siete
mil y ocho mil euros por hectárea ahora
bien imaginar la cantidad de dinero que
no se puede ganar si utilizamos toda esa
superficie para construir una fábrica o
un edificio de oficinas
entendéis ahora a lo que me refiero pues
bien es a todo esto
holanda es el líder mundial en
exportación de patatas por encima de
francia españa o incluso los mismísimos
eeuu
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
agricultura en europa seguro que hay
subvenciones de bruselas por algún sitio
de la agricultura es uno de los sectores
más protegidos y que más ayudas tiene en
toda la unión europea sin embargo países
bajos no es ni muchísimo menos el país
que más dinero recibe por supuesto
tienen sus ayudas como todos los demás
países miembros pero no llegan ni a la
tercera parte de lo que le pagan a
grecia por ejemplo
[Música]
y si lo comparamos con otros grandes
países como francia las diferencias son
abismales así que como es posible con
tan poco terreno y tan pocas ayudas
holanda haya llegado a ser el huerto del
mundo como os podéis imaginar la
respuesta es tan sencilla como una
palabra tecnología en una granja de
países bajos nos podemos encontrar
tractores que se conducen solos drones
que monitorizan los cultivos y por
supuesto optimización de recursos al más
alto nivel
sin embargo todavía queda una pregunta y
porque holanda tiene una agricultura más
moderna que por ejemplo españa que tiene
más ayudas de europa que han hecho en
los países bajos que se puede invitar en
otros países hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
del campo a la universidad en los años
70 holanda era una de las economías más
prósperas de europa empresas como
philips o airpass estaban conquistando
los mercados internacionales y todo esto
son buenas noticias pero como siempre
decimos en visual política no todo es
tan bonito imaginad que tenéis 20 años y
vivís en países bajos en esta época
donde queríais trabajar en una empresa
internacional como philips con unos
sueldos altos y unas buenas condiciones
o en la granja de vuestro padre exacto
la agricultura holandesa estaba al borde
de la desaparición
y esto hay que sumarle otra cosa muy
importante como os decíamos antes países
bajos es muy pequeño y apenas hay
espacio para grandes explotaciones
agrarias por ejemplo en eeuu hay terreno
de sobra y esto significa que los
agricultores se pueden agrupar y crear
grandes explotaciones
de hecho a día de hoy buena parte de las
granjas estadounidenses pertenece a
grandes empresas
esto significa que pueden hacer
inversiones de escala y por ejemplo
comprar una avioneta para fumigar
grandes extensiones de tierra sin
embargo en el caso de países bajos las
granjas son pequeñas el tamaño medio por
aquella época era y es todavía hoy de
alrededor de 7 hectáreas y con cultivos
tan pequeños es muy complicado hacer
grandes inversiones
al colmo para los años 70 los sueldos de
los holandeses ya eran mucho más altos
que los de otros países europeos en
otras palabras que a diferencia de los
agricultores del sur de italia los
grandes no podían competir con precios
bajos y os preguntaréis pero y por qué
necesitaban agricultura a fin de cuentas
por aquellos años ya existía cierta idea
de mercado internacional países bajos
podía dedicarse a importar la comida
mientras ellos se dedicaban a fabricar
televisiones o aviones verdad pues si
tenéis razón desde el punto de vista
puramente económico podrían haber
prescindido de su sector primario sin
tener el más mínimo problema
pero mis queridos amigos de visual
política no todo es economía en esta
vida y en un país como holanda las
asociaciones de campesinos tienen
muchísimo poder más que en casi
cualquier otro país
por ejemplo los que veáis este vídeo
desde españa habréis oído hablar de la
mesa del diálogo social verdad se trata
de un organismo en el que se reúne el
gobierno la patronal y los sindicatos
pues bien en países bajos tienen algo
muy parecido pero junto a la patronal y
los sindicatos también están
representadas las asociaciones de
agricultores y ganaderos en los años 70
los agricultores y ganaderos holandeses
no estaban dispuestos a cambiar de
trabajo así que ponemos en situación
holanda tenía que mantener su sector
primario a toda costa pero a la vez
todas las condiciones estaban en su
contra
[Música]
llegado desde punto ya me imagino lo que
estaréis pensando subvenciones la
solución es dar subvenciones a los
agricultores para que dejen de protestar
verdad desde luego no sería ni la
primera ni la última vez que se aplican
este tipo de políticas pero el gobierno
de holanda tenía otros planes y ha
puestos a tener que mantener al sector
primario querían hacerlo bien y como no
podían reducir los sueldos ni agrupar
las granjas sólo quedaba una solución
mejorar la productividad es decir que un
mismo tram hero produzca más y mejor
trabajando el mismo tiempo y eso cómo se
consigue pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la universidad de wageningen seguro que
lo habréis oído mil veces silicon valley
no sería lo que es hoy en día si no
fuera por la universidad de stanford se
trata de la meca de la investigación en
todo lo que tenga que ver con
electrónica y telecomunicaciones pero no
sólo se dedican a investigar también
forman a los informáticos mejor
preparados del mundo y según salen de la
universidad van directamente a trabajar
a esas grandes empresas como google
apple o tesla pues bien en lo que
agricultura se refiere la meca de la
innovación no está en eeuu sin - landa
sí amigos de visual políti estoy
hablando de la universidad de wageningen
también conocida como el fútbol y
probablemente muchos de vosotros nunca
hayáis oído hablar de esta universidad
esto se debe a que se limitan a trabajar
en el mundo de la agricultura
no tienen ni titulaciones de historia ni
de derecho ni nada parecido el lema de
bach mínguez es mejorar la calidad
alimentaria del mundo entero y os
preguntaréis pero que tiene esta
universidad que no tenga por ejemplo la
politécnica de madrid o la universidad
de chile de entrada la primera
diferencia es el dinero países bajo
sabía que necesitaba la tecnología para
mejorar su campo así que hicieron cubrir
a sus científicos de dinero en sólo dos
décadas el presupuesto para
investigación de la universidad de
wageningen se multiplicó por dos
pero esperad un momento porque el dinero
no es lo único importante en realidad lo
más importante no es cuánto sino el de
dónde venía ese dinero
en casi toda latinoamérica hay una línea
muy clara que separa la universidad
pública de la privada las universidades
públicas viven del estado punto por
supuesto que pueden tener algún tipo de
colaboración con la empresa privada pero
seamos honestos a duras penas llegan a
representar un mínimo porcentaje de la
financiación total el caso de bar
ninguén es distinto su modelo de
financiación consiste en que el 50 por
ciento del dinero lo pone el gobierno el
25 por ciento viene de los propios
ingresos de la universidad y el último
25% viene de las empresas privadas y ya
se lo que estaréis pensando muchos en
empresas privadas financiando la
universidad significa esto que la
universidad es privada por supuesto que
no pero tiene una gran ventaja permite
que la universidad esté conectada al
resto de la sociedad vale ya sé
perdóname esto ha sonado a chorrada de
político lo siento os lo voy a explicar
con un ejemplo para preparar este vídeo
hablé con varios ganaderos de españa
concretamente de las islas canarias para
que me explicarán cómo funciona la
modernización agrícola
seguramente no lo sepáis pero la
ganadería en canarias es muy importante
sobre todo la caprina tienen un tipo
específico de cabra la llamada cabra
palmera que es única en el mundo y
lógicamente hay varios institutos y
fundaciones que se dedican a estudiar a
este tipo de cabras sin embargo
prácticamente ninguno de los estudios
que se sacan tiene la más mínima
utilidad para los ganaderos pensadlo
bien si tenéis una explotación de cabras
qué tipo de investigación necesitáis
supongo que queréis saber cómo podéis
producir más y mejor leche verdad
estudios sobre cómo alimentar mejor a
los animales suplementos dietéticos o
incluso no sé ingeniería genética pues
bien si entráis en la web del icia por
ejemplo que es el instituto canario de
investigaciones agrícolas no vais a
encontrar nada por el estilo
ahora bien hay montones de artículos
académicos que te explican el origen
racial de la cabra palmera si están
alentadas con otras cabras de marruecos
o de tanzania o si ya existían durante
la edad media utilidad práctica
prácticamente cero mientras tanto según
el ranking que saca el times higher
education los estudios de wageningen son
los más citados en su campo
pero la cosa no se queda aquí a que no
adivinan cuál es la lengua oficial de
esta universidad seguramente pensaréis
que estando en países bajos hablarán en
hernández verdad pues nada de eso
hablamos de la capital mundial de la
investigación agrícola pero no es sólo
el número de estudiantes extranjeros en
las universidades técnicas holandesas
bate un nuevo récord en esta universidad
más del 40% de los estudiantes son
extranjeros y lo mismo ocurre con el
personal investigador no importa de
dónde seas si tienes talento para la
agricultura tienes tu sitio en bar
ninguén y por eso la lengua oficial es
el inglés
[Música]
nos explica que en birmingham sean por
ejemplo los pioneros en el uso de
lámparas led para los invernaderos
lámparas que permiten crear micro climas
artificiales controlados al milímetro
gracias a esto países bajos es uno de
los líderes en cultivo de tomate espesa
que en condiciones naturales los te
mates jamás crecerían en un país tan
frío pero no sólo eso en un país como
eeuu los granjeros necesitan unos 126
litros de agua para cultivar un kilo de
tomates pues bien gracias a las
investigaciones de esta universidad
ahora será posible producir lo mismo con
sólo 8 litros de agua imaginad el ahorro
que supone no sólo desde el punto de
vista económico sino también ecológico
pero esperad un momento porque esto de
la investigación está muy bien pero no
sirve de nada si se queda en la
universidad y en esto holanda también es
todo un ejemplo de cómo hacer las cosas
bien
[Música]
en la universidad al campo volvemos a
españa por un momento imagina que
tenemos un huerto con tomates y queremos
invertir en esta tecnología hidropónica
que nos va a permitir ahorrar el consumo
de agua
también europea y más concretamente la
política agraria común es decir la pac
da toda clase de subvenciones a los
agricultores para que modernizan sus
cultivos así que nos vamos a la llamada
agencia de extensión agraria que son las
oficinas donde gestionan estas ayudas
pues bien ahí nos van a dar el dinero y
se van a asegurar de que efectivamente
lo vamos a gastar para mejorar nuestras
técnicas de producción hasta aquí todo
muy bien todo perfecto pero como sabemos
que en máquinas tenemos que comprar
puede parecer evidente que un agricultor
sabe mejor que nadie lo que necesita
para su cultivo pero lo cierto es que el
mundo agrícola evoluciona tan rápido
como las empresas de internet y si nadie
nos asesora tendremos que buscar la
información por nuestra cuenta pues esa
es la situación en la que se encuentran
casi todos los agricultores españoles
hay una brecha gigantesca entre la
universidad y el campo
el caso holandés sin embargo es
totalmente distinta en este país existen
las llamadas oficinas de consejo
agrícola es decir que hay una persona
dedicada a explicarnos qué tipo de
máquinas deberíamos comprar y qué
tecnologías se adaptan mejor para
nuestro cultivo
el resultado el campo holandés no se
parece en nada al de ningún otro país
mientras españa es el mayor consumidor
de antibióticos de consumo animal de
toda europa
los ganaderos de países bajos ya están
utilizando las técnicas veterinarias más
punteras de tal forma que pueden
prevenir las enfermedades antes de
curarla si lo mismo ocurre con los
pesticidas que se utilizan para las
plantas en este país han descubierto que
se utilizan drones que monitorizan los
cultivos pueden controlar todos y cada
uno de los vegetales y evitar que
contraigan infecciones de ningún tipo
y nos país donde casi todos los cultivos
son de regadío han conseguido reducir el
consumo de agua en casi un 90%
y las exportaciones de productos
agrícolas superaron los 92 mil millones
de euros el año 2017
no sólo eso holanda también está ganando
dinero gracias a exportar su propia
tecnología
[Música]
emiratos árabes unidos usará sistemas
holandeses para garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria
pero no solo hablamos de los emiratos ya
os hemos cantado aquí en visual político
como singapur está empezando a
desarrollar granjas urbanas pues bien
este proyecto también lleva tecnología
holandesa así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que se pueden
importar este tipo de políticas en otros
países hasta qué punto estas tecnologías
que se desarrollan en holanda van a
permitir a alimentar al mundo entero
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que quien visual politics sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os haya
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto